don't want to welcome to this video so
young 23 is my opponent then she got
another one of those London's yeah
people play it it's not going to go away
so what is he up to Bishop d3 it's kind
of uncommon oh it's an early bishop
maybe maybe can irritate him a little
bit sorry Jim not sure if he yeah he
actually goes into the self pin one
thing that I wonder is but okay I can't
do this first if he's got some Queen a
for business but it's not really a
problem I think whenever your Bishop is
out there on g4 outside of the pawns
chain any pens here a little bit more
yeah should be considered more carefully
maybe Queen - really - okay he's called
he's just content with trading down okay
I just take a equalized comfortably I
have to castle first and then he five
and that is basically the signal that I
could equalized I don't think I have any
reason to consider this position to be
advantageous but it it's definitely fine
I've got a little bit of extra space
that is useful on the other hand the d5
pawn is some sometimes liability in such
a situation okay
to move the rook yeah how do we get
something going here 94 threatens mmm
sorry rook F 6
it's very what hello
I have an idea sometimes I mean a 5 is
entirely pointless mind it just blunders
f2 or is there a trick that I don't
understand I don't think some really
needed to move the Queen
prophylactically
yeah just no move the only thing I have
to look at a little bit is my back rank
which is slightly weak but I don't see
him doing anything on the DA Drakh I
mean I have to be always some alert that
there is not some tactical trick
happening but this is some just going to
win instantly Queen d3 rook g2 was made
made on f2 well now I have tomato kun f2
made that quickly went down the drain
yeah Bishop d3 is a bit uncommon and
that cannot be a terrible move of course
but it is a little bit unusual Queen to
b6 is suggested by the engine that does
make a lot of sense actually because the
natural reply Queen b3 it makes no sense
because of c4 you know yeah I'm
definitely fine yeah but I mean should
g5 can hardly be a mistake at a 3 6 9 BD
- yeah I don't think there is any Queen
a for coming because I can take here
before he gets to e5
and T I'm definitely fine even c4 is an
eidm came home
no the ship t6 I think that makes sense
trying to trade and gain more control
over a 5 the engine suggests Queens to
suggests Queen to b3 that is an
interesting choice after who could be 8
yeah even that is a possibility
I never pawned down maybe I'll get it
back because both of those parts they
look a little bit unstable yeah Queen c7
now probably okay but should takes Queen
takes age 3 yeah I can do that but I
probably will take the anyway or some
current some point okay
castles we got e5 and everything traded
and now you probably have to start to
make adjustments here nothing special
because the position is equal but I
think if why two things about this a
little bit where to put pieces this
Bishop should definitely be here on g2
to put some pressure on the pawn it's
just totally wrong only three because
you have you don't attack the d5 pawn
which is what you should try to do it
it's no coincidence the engine gives
Queen c2 that's the engine nine and this
should be true that is very logical
trying to regroup
I mean it is just equal if I have want
equality I can push d4 and we basically
go home yeah nothing the whole board
trades down but that's what white should
do I'm sorry Queenie a three it's not a
mistake but it leads it leads nowhere
now then another is a series of weird
moves but should be 5 is
not sure what this does and anyway they
for okay that's centralized and now he
has to play some prophylactic move yeah
the engine gives Queenie to or queen f4
these are basically the only Queen moves
that he can play otherwise the queen is
just dropping stuff so you just go back
and then it continues I'm not sure how I
continue to play I'm only on the sixth
rank because he he had forced me to do
that so I'm not married to the plan of
an attack here well I can try I can play
route g6 or f6 at least trying to
provoke weaknesses but the engine gives
0.1 and that's what it is yeah after a 5
it's just over he didn't pay any
attention to what what I was doing I
think Dan OBM in checkmate territory and
it's made either with queen f2 or 9f2
so yeah fairly sudden end to this game
it is important this kind of structure
arises very frequently oftentimes
actually with colors reversed yeah then
white has this kind of Center and black
has this kind of setup often coming from
Scandinavian from Recaro sometimes from
a French defense yeah these kind of
structures and the friendship probably
have the bishop here which makes the
huge difference but caro-kann and
scandinavian mostly and yeah you should
try to make some pressure here also from
the can also happen from the from the
Slav with the color servers you should
try to pressurize the pawn I think it's
just equal but it's what you should do
okay guys thanks arching